okay it is my great pleasure to
introduce Howard Zinn a respected
professor historian and author of the
landmark a people's history of the
United States 1492 to the present he has
taught at Boston University in Spelman
College would you all please join me in
welcoming Howard Zinn
thank you
thank you
I'm putting my watch down to pretend
that I care but I don't know how much
you know about my book or what's in the
book maybe you know everything I have to
say to you but I will talk about my book
because I don't know what else to talk
about I'll tell you how I came to write
it and why I came to write it in this
funny way and I I wrote the book in the
late 1970s I guess when I had some
breathing space after the anti-war
movement yeah you know during the
anti-war movement we were all doing all
these furious things you know there's
you know the center you know many of you
know this the war was the center of our
lives and we were running around the
country and doing this and that and and
there's no time it's certainly no time
to write a 700 page book so I was
putting out little things you know a
hundred and 25 page book called Vietnam
the logical withdrawal and a hundred
page book called disobedience and
democracy yeah you know no more time so
but now I had time so I decided to write
what people had been looking for or at
least people would approach me and say
you know you've been teaching American
history and so on can you recommend a
good one volume history of the United
States from a radical point of view No
well not really
yeah I don't want to go into
bibliographical detail about what there
is and what there isn't but not exactly
you know but these were the demands that
came out of the movements of the 60s do
you know the movements of the 60s people
were looking for something different
people were remembering kind of history
they had learned in high school and
college and was thinking this doesn't
fit what I see in the world today and so
they were looking for something and just
so I decided to write something to to
fill that need know clearly those of you
know the book came I know that I came to
that history from a very definite point
of view and I guess this is because when
I began to study history when I began to
when I decided I would that's what I
would do I would write history and I
would teach history I already knew that
I was not going to be a neutral teacher
I was not going to be a neutral
historian I have a memoir called notice
how I'm advertising all my books
business a book festival yeah yeah I
have many more you'll hear many more
things like that and I'll just try not
to mention other people's books but we
but I yeah I wrote a memoir called you
can't be neutral on a moving train and
then the idea of is it came from things
I would say to my class is at the
beginning of the class I would say now
look you know this is not gonna be a
neutral class there's not gonna be one
of those classes and well you spent a
semester or a year with a teacher at the
end of the semester at the end of the
year you have no idea where this teacher
stands on the important issues of the
day we've all had teachers like that
right a lot of them no I wasn't gonna be
neutral I had a point of view a strong
point of view and I wasn't gonna hold
back on it because I didn't believe they
well you might say had a very modest
desire and going into history I just
wanted to change the world
and I figured you can't change the world
if you're neutral and besides to be
neutral no oh well look the world is
already moving in certain directions
there's no such there's no real thing
neutrality it doesn't exist the world is
already moving in certain directions
wars are going on children are going
hungry terrible things are being done to
be neutral in such a world is to
collaborate with what is going on and so
no I wasn't gonna be neutral as a
historian and and yes I kind of knew as
I started write this book what my point
of view it was going to be and it came
out of my background it came out of my
life experience it came out of the fact
that at the age of 18 I didn't go to
college I went to work in a shipyard
stayed in the shipyard for three years I
didn't do it as a sociological
experiment ah let's go in to view the
shipyard workers and do an oral history
of shipyard workers yeah no that wasn't
it you know I just came from that kind
of background that kind of family that
kind of neighborhood and working-class
parents and so on struggling no no
thought of going to college when you got
18 everybody around me I went to work at
the age of 18 so I worked in a shipyard
for three years and helped organize the
young shipyard workers who are excluded
from the AFL unions black people were
excluded from the unions women were
excluded from the unions unskilled
workers work and so we formed the kind
of industrial Union and IWW almost
that's what we like to think you know
whenever we do something good we like to
compare ourselves to the IWW
I think and we were so I might say I
grew up class-conscious with a phrase
you don't hear much in the United States
you know that is not supposed to we're
not supposed to have classes in the
United States we're all one big happy
family
you see all of our interests are the
same you know Exxon and me you know
and you know the founding fathers and
all of us you know the I mean the very
you know name founding fathers we're
related by blood to those slave owners
who sat in on the making of the
Constitution yeah no we're we're no
we're not one big family despite the
attempts on the part of the
establishment to draw us all in to this
net and say our interests are one you
hear them talking about oh this is this
in our national interest is this in the
interest of national security
actually maybe in the interest of
somebody's securities but not in the
interest of national security you see
but all these we're all these phrases
supposed to envelop us all in one common
bond of interest and stand thus hiding
the fact that we are Society of many
different interests of people who are
rich people who are poor and a lot of
people in between who are nervous and so
we you know a black and white and men
and women and immigrants no it's it's
it's a society of people in in stressful
relationship with one another
and so I wanted to write a history which
would be from a class conscious point of
view I wasn't going to write about the
founding fathers and the making of the
Constitution and you know and glorify
the Constitution which was written by 55
rich white men in Philadelphia I wasn't
gonna do that even though you know I was
taken aback for a moment when you know
Ronald Reagan during the bicentennial
year of the Constitution in 1987 Ronald
Reagan wrote an essay could you believe
that
runway wrote an essay for us you know
some scholarly magazine Parade magazine
in which he talked about the
Constitution and said you know that the
Constitution could only have been
created with a guiding hand of God you
know well I thought this was really an
insult to God when you consider you know
the Constitution was written to
perpetuate the wealth to perpetuate
slavery to fetch weight things as they
were to replace the British ruling class
with a local ruling class that's what
the Constitution was written for I'm
sorry to be so harsh on founding fathers
they're nice guys they look good they
dress well yeah you know they're very
eloquent but no I was gonna write about
history from from I I didn't want to
write about American industrial progress
as it was presented to me in high school
it's presented to me in high school I'm
never sitting there in class and now
this is the period of the great American
industrial revolution when America
became a great economic power you know
that period between the Civil War and
World War one when when you know I
remember sitting there transfixed as the
figures were put up on the board of how
many more steel ingots were being
produced each year you know how many
miles of railroad track and the
Transcontinental Railroad wow how
romantic and how beautiful and we were
so proud nothing was said in those
classes and nothing was said in my
textbooks about who worked on those
railroads about the Irish immigrants and
the Chinese immigrants who worked on
those railroads and died in great
numbers in the sickness in the heat in
those railroads I was going to I was
going to tell about the great industrial
miracle of the United States that
leaving out the girls who went to work
in the textile mills of New England at
the age of 12 and died at the age of 25
and I wasn't going to look at the the
state of the country from the
standpoint of the Dow Jones average no I
mean leave this if you look historically
you know and I was sort of prepared for
this by by some of my working and in
history that's prepared looking back at
eras which had been triumphantly
proclaimed as wonderful eras you know
remember the era of goodwill they still
have that in the textbooks but I
certainly have you know the the roaring
20s the Jazz Age the age of prosperity I
mean history is very simple the twenties
were prosperous everybody was prosperous
in the 20s and everybody was depressed
in the 30s so but I did I was doing a
study of Fiorello LaGuardia mine my
first book mention another book yes
never miss an opportunity first my
doctoral dissertation Archie was on
Fiorello LaGuardia and a lot of
you-know-who fever a little gaudy is
some people yes Sammy some people you
know think you know he's an airport no
but he was you know a lot of people know
he was mayor of New York for a colorful
character but before that a lot of
people don't know this and I didn't know
this until I started working him he was
a congressman in the 1920s representing
East Harlem representing a poor district
of Harlem an interesting congressman was
radical member of Congress he was a
Republican and a socialist don't ask
don't ask don't ask me to explain that
you say but but I was read the letters
in that laguardia's constituents were
writing to him from East Harlem in the
1920s in the age of prosperity the Jazz
Age and these the letters from his
constituents were saying help me my
husband is out of work my kids don't
have enough to eat they turned off the
gas you know and and it was true all
over the country but nobody noticed it
because the headlines were about the
Wall Street and the stock market and how
well it was doing and and you know I
mean you learn about today when you read
about history if you don't learn about
today if you learn don't learn about
today when you're learning about history
then there's no not much point you know
except fun
oh yeah you can have fun but I never
wanted to be a historian who went into
the past and got lost you know there are
you know you're going past is
interesting you go in and you read those
letters and the documents and it's
detective work and it's fun you know but
you can get lost there and that I didn't
want to do that I wanted to see what I
could find and come out and apply it to
what was going on in the world
I left a shipyard to enlist in the Air
Force
and you can tell I'm a kind of military
person and but it was it was there was a
war on
no not the spanish-american war
no the world war 2 the war against
fascism and I was imbued it's a lot of
young yeah young radicals were computing
young everybody yes the war against
fascism lets you know and so III I
became a bombardier in the Air Force and
flew vomit and drop bombs and wear draw
bombs are dropped
meaning not where they're intended to go
sometimes where they are intended to go
which sometimes is worse but in any case
I became a bomb at the air and and but I
came out of this this is a good war as
you know right this is the the best of
wars I wrote a book I wrote a book once
called post-war America and I had a
chapter in it about world war two and
chapter was called the best of wars and
Studs Terkel you know wrote the good war
yeah later and and but a wonderful book
if you notice if you look at a book
closely the phrase the good war in Studs
Terkel z' book is surrounded by
quotation marks yeah because it's not
that simple it's not that clear it's not
that unambiguous it's very complicated
and I came out of that good war in which
I had been an eager Bombardier came out
of the war convinced that war solves
nothing
our Lord doesn't solve fundamental human
problems and even when it seems to do so
even when it starts off looking that way
even when the enemy is vicious and you
because the enemy is vicious you look
good
this is a common mistake mistake is that
if the enemy is evil you must be good
well it was I came out of the war
persuaded that war yeah well it didn't
take long they were those promises made
in World War two those promises me know
this would be we're gonna defeat fascism
and we're gonna have a wonderful new
world yeah right we'd have a world you
know we're not gonna have racism anymore
because we're gonna defeat Hitler Hitler
represents racism we're not gonna have
war anymore and I got militarism anymore
no we're not the UN we're gonna have
yeah well it doesn't take much
observation of the years that follow
World War two to begin to ask the
question if 50 million people died in
World War two what did they die for for
this kind of world with a perpetuation
of war and militarism and racism and yes
and fascism all nooks and crannies all
over the world including our own country
fascism is not confined to national
boundaries fascism exists in every
prison in this country really yeah
and there exists in the military there
there you know yeah so anyway the point
is that from this point on if I was
gonna deal in history with war and
writing history teaching history I had a
very strong point of view and the point
of view was anti-war and my personal
experience like dropping napalm on a
little village in France toward the end
of the war and killing German Frenchmen
who ever happened to be there basically
to test out napalm that's the only
reason I could figure out for doing it
was the first use of napalm it's and
then watching the bombing of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki and all and then reading
John Hersey and having the the stories
of the people no children caught in in
that no I was I wasn't going to be
neutral on a question of war and I was
gonna look at war from the standpoint of
the Statesman and that the
decision-makers are the generals I was
gonna look at war from the standpoint of
the GIS and the soldiers and the the the
young men cajoled and coerced into going
to war i was also wanted to look at war
from the standpoint of the other side
yeah and this is something you don't
think about let's look at war from the
standpoint of the enemy the other people
right let's look at a mexican war from
and point to the Mexicans well when you
look at the Mexican walked on the
standpoint of the Mexicans well here we
are we're in Mexican territory I'm right
we this is this was part of Mexico and
we stole it no other word for it we we
provoked a war with Mexico so that we
could take half of Mexico
some people thought we were being
moderate we should have taken all of
Mexico but no we took no I wanted to
tell a story of Mexico of that war yeah
from the standpoint of the GIS who woke
up one day American immigrant kids who
just Adam for the same reason that most
young people join Wars join out of
desperation and and need and desire to
to get ahead or whatever you know and
then find themselves in a bloody mess
which they want any part of and so they
began deserting from the American army
in the Mexican War
yeah from their point of view and from
the plans 20 beautiful of all Mexicans
and so you know so it was my experience
and it was history also when I looked at
the history of wars and history of
America's war see I know are there a
good Wars and bad wars
well good war isn't bad we have these
lists right good wars and bad Wars I had
a student once who wrote you know they
treat Wars like wines because there's a
good year this is a bad year but war is
not like wine was like cyanide one drop
in you're dead and and all the
experience of you know in all the other
wars since the war to end all wars since
World War two
so confirmed you know what I felt about
war and you know and of course right up
to this very day now and I wanted to one
of the things I wanted to get across to
students is to lose their subservience
to power lose their subservience to our
authority
who's there subservience to the
so-called experts and there was no more
vivid lesson during the Vietnam War than
lesson about experts and I remember
people at the beginning of the anti-war
movement saying wait a while you know
these people in Washington I mean why do
you think they're there they know what
they're doing really really I mean just
look at the history of what people in
Washington have done and asked they know
what they're doing I mean they they're
gonna be Phi Beta Kappa and they were in
the Kennedy and Johnson administration
they were the best and the brightest
they were the smart right and and and
they engaged in the most stupid and most
immoral set of actions that we've had in
the history of our country for a long
time so I wanted my students to learn to
think for themselves and to to stew
learn and seek out information to
themselves not to depend you know on the
what the president says what the
immediate say or what the textbook said
but not even what my book said but to
look things up for themselves and make
up make up their own minds so and then
after I I'm continuing my little
autobiographical romp you see year by
year only take a few hours
and the
Sonia I went to college under the GI
Bill I love it when people say the era
you know we mustn't have big government
we mustn't in government do things to
people right government is doing too
much for mothers taking care of kids who
are collecting a $350 a month's really
you know government's not good it treats
dependency oh really
when we give billions of dollars to the
corporations that create dependency no
no big government and it was different
during the New Deal when people began to
realize government although government
has mostly been on the side of the rich
and powerful it is possible sometimes
the government to do something for the
poor as it did in the 1930s when the
passed Social Security of course under
the impetus of social movements under
the impetus of the labor movement and so
on and the evidence of strikes all over
the country and tenant strikes and so on
but good things were done by government
in that time ha ha and people have
forgotten about that and some people
deliberately want to forget about that
me say big government is no good but the
GI Bill was big government it was the
government yeah giving four years of
free education to everybody who served
in World War two and so I went through
my entire educational thing right up
through the PhD never paid a dollar in
tuition I know the young people looking
at me rather enviously at this point
yeah so I studied history NYU Columbia
my first teaching job Spelman College
Atlanta Georgia black women's college
and the Marion arrived yet no she may
never know she'll rise
yes you'll arrive but seven years at
Spelman College my wife and kids got
into our old Chevy and went down to
Atlanta and spent the next seven years
1956 to 63 a very special time to be in
the south and to be living in the black
community and to see the verse that the
the you know the tremor is under the
surface begin to develop and then see
things burst out in 1960 you know with
their sit-ins and 61 with the Freedom
Rides and 62 and 63 in Albany Georgia
and Birmingham and the mass
demonstrations and the thousands and
tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands of people being involved an
amazing amazing episode in our history
out of which I learned an enormous
amount I certainly learned more from my
years at Spelman and my students learned
from me I learned a lot about politics I
learned about education I learned a lot
about democracy I learned about well one
thing I learned about education you know
the business of yeah you see history
from a different point of view you look
at history from a black point of view it
looks different you know look history
from a woman's point of view it looks
different from yeah
and from the Native American point of
view from Native American point of view
take the Revolutionary War as we know
that was a good war right on how can you
beat the Revolutionary War I you know
there are the statues all over the I
mean here I come from Boston now in
Boston would die if not for the
Revolutionary War and the statues that
it can have in its public square a but
Boston needs the room you know all of
that but and the Revolutionary War yes
it's it's freed us from England from
point of view of the Indians it was a
disaster the British had set a line
beyond which the colonists could move
west into Indian Territory proclamation
of 1763 we win the war against England
we abolish the line
then we move into Indian Territory and
all across the country and then follows
a hundred years of massacres right
another so very neglected set of
episodes in American history uh well I
learned about was Sitting Bull at
Custer's last stand but from history
from black point of view looks look
certainly different the heroes look
different
the all the traditional heroes look
different the eras and their names look
different you know everybody learns
about the progressive everybody takes
American history learns about the
Progressive Era in American history
right they still they must still have
that in the book always the progressive
here the first 20 years of the 20th
century when it's called a progressive
area because very various reforms were
passed you know the railroad regulation
and the Meat Inspection Act notice how
good our meat is as a result of that and
the you know Federal Reserve System the
Federal Trade Commission the direct
election Senators etc here graduated
income tax I noticed how graduated our
income taxes these days
yeah well anyway but the reform so it's
the Progressive Era those are exactly
the years it was that in that
progressive here when more black people
were lynched in this country than in any
other period of American history so you
know I began to read the black
historians who are not on my reading
lists in Columbia oh really they were
not and then of course I learned you
know well just by becoming involved in a
movement just becoming involved in that
movement that you know that my students
initiated they always think that faculty
you know when other students are evolved
you know it's that during the Vietnam
what I think faculty must whom some
faculty person must have instigated it's
never that way the students started the
faculty people come in you know some but
you learn about learned a lot about
education learned that education is not
simply what you get in a classroom it's
what you learn out in the midst of a
social struggle
I remember when my students when Marian
and a whole bunch of other students of
Spelman and Morehouse etc were getting
arrested in downtown Atlanta for sitting
in one of my colleagues a political
scientist PhD from Johns Hopkins I want
to give him his full do before I wrote a
letter to the Atlanta Constitution
deploring that his students were missing
class and going downtown to participate
in these demonstrations their education
they're losing out on their education
well obviously this man was losing out
on his education he didn't understand
about education wise and didn't
understand that people learn more in the
heat of social struggle than they can
simply buy books in classrooms short
books and classrooms are good and you
come back from the picket line
and come back to the classroom and you
want to read more and learn more I want
to read more history of what it is you
are involved with so yeah I learned a
lot I learned I learned from my students
I learned well I learned never to
mistake
silence for agreement you know not
because look you looked at the surface
it looks came to Spelman College and I
gave hippies six things that look quiet
everybody is well-behaved
people are going you know they're doing
their lessons they're gonna do the right
things to become successful do what
their parents want them to do and and
become you know some people of some
substance and use in the black
segregated community right well that's
the way it looked and you could looking
at that surface of quiet and silent you
would say as some people so many people
say about students today or about people
today where are they they're not doing
anything you know never look at the
surface of things this is what I learned
I always assume that if something is
wrong there's a under the surface
there's a kind of uh net
common sense understanding as something
is wrong I believe in this country
there's a common on sense understanding
that is something wrong with spending
two hundred seventy billion dollars on
weaponry when forty million people are
without health insurance and and
healthier other you know people
understand that you know and people
fundamentally understand things you know
and but very often they're quiet about
it they're practical they're waiting for
the right moment they're waiting for
somebody to make the first move and and
so you know that a certain point that my
students at Spelman burst out you know
of that silence and they and young
people and older people all over the
south of black people all of the South
just galvanized the country and the
world and embarrassed the US government
into finally doing something one of the
things we learned at that time you don't
depend on the government don't depend on
even the most liberal government I mean
we have had liberal governments and
conservative governments we have
Democrats and Republicans for a hundred
years in this country after the passage
of the 14th amendment 14th man was
supposed to guarantee racial equality
and and didn't matter who was in power
in Washington they didn't do a thing to
enforce the 14th amendment until black
people in 1950s and 1960s came out on
mass and embarrassed the government of
the United States and doing some time
and that was when democracy came alive
democracy is not a set of of procedures
it's not a framework democracy is people
giving you something to drink when
you're thirsty
and yes oh yeah democracy came alive in
the 60s no democracy as I said is not
you know it's not what we learned in
junior high school ah this is this is
democracy I'm gonna put it on the
blackboard there are the three branches
of government executive legislative
judicial is the Constitution that's
democracy vote every two year four years
that's the month no no if we depended on
that we would be lost more than we are
the thing that changed things to the
extent that they did change for black
people for working people in this
country for women for disabled people
the people who against what things the
government of the United States did not
initiate any other things that were
necessary to remedy those grievances
people had to go out and create
movements in order to bring that about
and then if the movement became strong
enough and loud enough and persistent
enough then the government responded
well that was the lesson of democracy so
what else should I say what what other
books of mine haven't I mentioned
what's that
well maybe maybe it's possible but how
abouts questions
how about questions yes I'm finished
yeah
yeah there's a microphone set up right
back there in case people came over tax
oh is it bad if people speak from their
seats
yeah does c-span not like that
what do you think we're doing this for
like what if you want people to line up
behind the mic okay is it is can people
speak from this east is that Alright
and then I repeat the question and
distort it as I usually do okay yes yes
go ahead
and then the big revolt was called deaf
president now and deaf people really
mobilize and then they close the
university at that time called the
college they closed it for a week to do
the Deaf president now revolt so I'm
wondering that had a large impact on
American history at least deaf people
think so but I was looking and the
section about history during that period
of time and there was no mention at all
of deaf president now
so it hasn't really impacted American
history according to the books my my
book or books generally including my
book yeah really I'm I'm ashamed to say
that but time to time people have
pointed out things I've missed in my
book you know I've missed a lot yeah and
and you know when the first edition the
book came out I I really didn't do
justice to the struggles of Chicano
people in this country I didn't do
justice as struggles of gay and lesbian
people in this country didn't do justice
to the struggles of disabled people or
you know to this event which was a
remember that advantage and to me was
such a perfect example of democracy
coming alive where you know the students
protest in this remarkable way to have a
president who represents their own
situation yeah and that was a wonderful
event and I'm gonna make note of it so
the next time there's another printing
of my book and the printings come fast
so I I will make it really I'll make a
note of that
I wish you send me some stuff okay you
do you do email do you do email
no I'm not a card first yes I have email
yeah but I don't know your email lack
I'll tell you my email address it's God
everybody's listening
don't listen HSN HSN at be you dot e-d-u
got it H is in and B you being like his
boy dot DD you yes that the World War 2
was just another imperialist war of
being fought between two powers trying
to capture territory but then after
World War two seeing what Hitler had
done seeing what the role of Hitler had
been some of us changed began to think
about that war as maybe it was painful
necessary to fight in it what I just
wondered what you whether you had
changed and in your estimation that do
you want me to repeat though I had to
repeat that oh yeah she's asking me the
most difficult question that I get that
question a lot and it is I'm if I could
wreck it if I could know in advance that
a person would ask that question I
wouldn't recognize them
because this but there there it is it's
out she's asking me out World War two
and saying that she started off with a
notion it's an imperialist war you know
imperialist on both sides but then when
what were the stories of the death camps
you know when the Holocaust and all of
that you changed my mind about the war
it's the reason I say it's a tough
question because it's very very complex
you know and you know let me say this
something had to be done about fascism
right something had to be done about
Hitler the only question is but it had
to be done in the way that it was done
and whether it didn't come late you say
late because the main concern of the
nations fighting the war was not the
Jews and not racism and not militarism
it wasn't their concern you see and but
it's true that even you know there are
unintended consequences of bad
intentions right and so the thing the
thing I would come away from that's a
world war two is complex we did not have
to kill huge numbers of civilians in
German cities and we didn't have to drop
the bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki and
I didn't have to drop napalm on this
little town in France so something had
to be done about fascism and and the
question that's left is was there any
way to fight against fascism without at
some point in the war beginning to
duplicate the atrocities of the other
side you see I mean that's a big
question and it's a very unanswerable
question because it's all gone
the only I'll just say one more thing
the problem with world war two having
such elements of goodness and
questioning about it the problem with it
is that is the ambiguity of World War
two a problem with that is that to the
extent that World War two can be seen as
a good war it cast a soft glow on every
war that has followed since Wars which
don't have that amber
beauty was which crass imperial wars but
world what who is used it's used as a
metaphor and seems to justify Korea
Vietnam the Gulf War possibly it's they
pull it out every time you see to to
help them justify unjustifiable killing
so World War two has passed the real
question is how do we react to the wars
today and how do we react to the wasting
our enormous national treasures on
preparation for war yes I wanted to ask
about your involvement with the end of
sanctions against the Iraq campaign not
my involvement with what the end the
sanctions against Iraq campaign my
involvement with the sanctions against
the Iraq campaign ah you all know about
the sanctions against Iraq you all know
that we've been carrying on ever since
the Gulf War it's interesting how many
Americans don't know about if you took a
poll in the United States and asked of
how you would find most Americans do not
know that we've been carrying on a
campaign of sanctions which have killed
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
children children in Iraq which leads me
to a parenthetical remark no I'll hold
that
let me know when Marian arrives somebody
you know like we have a spotter and but
I mean I haven't been involved been
involved in it except talking about it
you know and telling if I haven't been
one of those heroic people who in the
voices of the wilderness who have those
people who are breaking the law of the
American law and and bringing food and
medicine to Iraq and they've done it you
know 15 16 times and one most shameful
episodes in recent American history
carried on by you know the liberal
Clinton administration really and
justified by it in the most awful ways
and the
Emily any sort of there's an enormous
disproportion of attention to atrocities
depending on what the people in power
want us to pay attention to and I mean
all trust me should be paid attention to
but the fact is if thousands of people
are killed in Kosovo that is brought to
our attention and it should be brought
to our attention
although the thousands of people we then
kill in bombing in order presumably to
do something about that's not brought to
our attention and the hundreds of
thousands of people who dies are sort of
our sanctions
that's not brought to our attention we
have a real problem in getting past what
the media tells us is important and
deciding for ourselves on the basis of
searching out independent sources of
information deciding for ourselves what
really is important I don't know what
else I can say about I don't I have a
feeling that you know sometimes behind
questions you know there's an answer
right that is the people who ask the
questions they know the answer they want
right and that I feel is an answer you
wanted but you didn't get am i right no
actually I just I saw your name in the
newspaper with with many other scholars
and I just wondered how you got involved
with the issue well you wonder how I got
involved that's easy
getting involved is easy you know people
get to know after a while who would get
involved in such a thing easily and you
know and if you know in you know I you
know if I can you know be on you know
the list of American Airlines who but I
can certainly be on the stop sanctions
against Iraq list yes oh there's a man
way back there who's hella stand up for
a long time
or private enterprise to provide at
least sufficient shelters for the
homeless particularly in our urban
centers because I recall some time ago a
man who wanted to open up I think a
deserted post office warehouse right
next to the White House and he had to
fast and he finally got on TV and
somehow the federal government opened up
that warehouse for temporary shelter I
mean again along with your point about
four hundred and forty four million
people not insured in our country with
health insurance
it's very shameful that we cannot
provide at least shelter for the
homeless is it not I mean that's
obviously not shame is it not shameful
yes that's an easy one right because the
politics that the homeless people don't
vote right yeah and a lot of you know
and they would it it and very often you
know people who are the most most agree
most harassed have the least resources
to fight back and therefore they depend
on the rest of us to speak up for them
like prisoners in jail who are not in a
position to fight back you know and who
in you know and and they need people on
the outside to advocate for them and the
same thing is true of the homeless it's
you know instead asking how surely we
should ask why isn't the government
doing this and we should ask you know
why aren't the people who have homes
speaking up and loud voices for the
homeless who's had a hand up for a long
time
alright go ahead
yes individual acts of violence is part
of revolution and what you think is
there separation is there a time at
which individual acts of violence
effective and a good idea as opposed to
war hmm gasps maybe you've got did
you'll get that no that's just about I
obviously speaking against the violence
of war and she asked me what about the
violence and individuals I assume you
mean the violence of individuals
presumably for some good purpose right
and well it always looks violence is
very tempting because it very often
seems to offer a quick solution for a
problem that you face but it's poisonous
it's it has consequences
which simply spread the idea of violence
it's and which reinforce the acts of
violence that are carried on on a large
scale in fact the two things reverberate
the government's acts of violence I
believe encourage those individual acts
of violence which then are deplored oh
how horrible if they you know they
they've you know blow up the right to
the building and Oklahoma City or they
you know they do this and and that's
looked upon with horror by the same of
people who were ready to kill thousands
of people and have you know in bombing
campaigns there's a connection between
it to this connection between violence
and schools and violence and streets and
violence that comes out of Washington
and we will - you know think about that
kind of hypocrisy but I don't I don't
believe that violence is a solution I
think the the poet June Jordan who lives
think somewhere in the bay area talked
when she talked about the Gulf War and I
said wars is life is like crack it's a
quick fix and then you know when it it's
over you know you realize what what what
terrible harm has been done I think the
great the great problem for human
ingenuity in this next hundred years now
that we're you know at this date an
account that we like to talk about the
next hundred years very wisely and but I
think that you know the problem yeah is
how do we solve the fundamental problems
of hunger and disease you know and
injustice and how do we do it without
killing large numbers of people that is
how do we do it while they're announcing
war you know as a solution you know
that's the huh I mean that's what I mean
that's what human ingenuity is should be
used for
I didn't want her to miss my talk okay
I'm starting over I'm gonna do the whole
thing over again
oh yeah great to see you
thank you I don't think she deserves a
moment full of arrest oh yeah you can't
hear me